لحظات ينتظرها الجميع بفارغ الصبر
رغم مرور عشره ايام على زلزال كهرمان مراش
تخرج فرق الانقاذ امراه وطفليها احياء في
مدينه انطاكيا بولايتها
امراه في كهرمان مراش مركز الزلزال المدمر
نجت ايضا بعد بقائها تحت الانقاض ل22 ساعه
وهذه المسنه ذات 77 عاما انقذت بعد تسعه
ايام من بقائها تحت انقاض منزلها في اليمن
مشاهد يامل الجميع ان تكثر وتتكرر بمرور
الوقت لما لها من تاثير في نفوس ذوي
الضحايا وهمه ومعنوياتي فرق الانقاذ
تمكنت فرق الانقاذ من اخراج شخص اخر ما
زال على قيد الحياه من تحت الانقاض في
قهرمان مرعش وما نزال نعلق الامال على
الوصول الى مزيد من الناجين زملائنا في
الميدان يواصلون العمل بكل عزم واخلاص
امثله كثيره النجفها اشخاص بعد مرور الوقت
المقدر فيه بقائهم احياء تحت الانقاض
ومنها رجل بقي حيا بعد 12 يوما تحت
الانقاض التي خلفها زلزالها عام 2010
الثابت ان الامل باخراج احياء لا يخضع
لمنطق الارقام والقياس الى حالات سابقه
ولا ترضمه قتامه مشاهد الخراب فهو دائما
فسحه لا سقف لها ولا حدود